I wonder if Birds dislike rainy days
good morning Hank it's Tuesday I don't
know much about what it's like to be a
bird and yet I'm more like a bird than I
am like almost anything I'm trying to
get some high quality footage of birds
to officially emphasize my point but
whatever you know what they look like
but I'm more like a bird than I am like
a bacterium right or like a tree and yet
I have absolutely no idea what it's like
to be a bird what what are their days
like I've been thinking a lot recently
about the limits of human empathy not to
be a bummer but over a hundred fifty
thousand people are gonna die today and
if I felt as strongly about all of their
deaths as I would about a death in my
family I wouldn't be able to function
right so I understand that empathy needs
to have limits but like I feel like my
empathy is is too limited so this
sycamore tree is actually older than the
moving image so I'm filming something
that existed before the idea of filming
something do birds enjoy the smell of
pine trees do they dwell on their past
failures do they feel a kind of
low-level background anxiety all the
time
I don't know all right let's get the
weather post cast with yesterday's
iPhone John it's raining which may or
may not be pleasant for Birds I don't
know of course strategies for limiting
empathy are built right into our
language like think about the English
word used to describe people in the 19th
century disabled by tuberculosis
invalid they were literally called
invalid invalids were often unable to
get out of bed which made it difficult
for them to participate in the social
interactions that were deemed essential
to humanity from worship services to
participating in physical chores and
when you read Memoirs by people who
identified as invalids in the 19th
century they often express a feeling
that the world is ignoring them and has
left them behind as if the full empathy
of their Community cannot extend to them
because they've become invisible because
they are somehow invalid I mean buying
this 30-foot microphone cord is a single
best decision of my entire life so far
but of course there's nothing invalid
about living with illness except that
our social order makes it so am I on
screen
I can't really tell I'm just gonna oh
that's me anyway reading about how bad
we were at listening to the sick in the
19th century has really helped emphasize
for me how bad we still are at it like
about 93 of all humans who are currently
alive will eventually die of illness I'm
down here by the way a phenomenon so
common that we refer to such deaths As
Natural as in the sentence they died of
natural causes so being sick isn't
unnatural or invalid it's literally
Universal and yet still we try to
explain away or deny other people's
suffering we say oh it's all in their
head or oh that happened because they
smoked cigarettes or because they ate
these Foods illness is not some moral
narrative and conceiving of it that way
is yet another barrier to empathy I
guess the thing about birds is that we
can't listen to them or at least we
haven't yet figured out a way to listen
to them well but we can listen to other
people like people in the 19th century
could have listened to invalids I know
because I've just read a bunch of their
Memoirs I guess they're probably is
something inherently isolating about
illness right like when I had meningitis
I was very rarely alone except in my
fear and pain where I was always alone
but there is something I can do I can't
know what it's like to be a bird and I
can't know what it's like to have
someone else's pain but I can listen to
other people when they tell me of their
pain and I can believe them in short we
validate each other
Hank I'll see you on Friday